a los soldados ucranianos que defienden
badmud solo les queda una vía para
entrar y salir de la ciudad las fuerzas
rusas han cortado el acceso a todas las
demás carreteras
están intentando empujarnos y rodearnos
para que tengamos que abandonar la
ciudad pero aún no ha funcionado Por
supuesto que tenemos pérdidas pero nos
las estamos arreglando y resistiendo
el escenario de la batalla más larga
desde el inicio de la invasión desde
hace meses
Moscú ha tratado de capturar la urbe un
asalto encabezado por mercenarios de la
empresa privada rusa al grupo Wagner con
la ciudad bajo un nuevo ataque este
lunes backmuth Parece ser el centro de
una nueva gran ofensiva rusa según dijo
el secretario general de la otan a
medida que se acerca el primer
aniversario de la invasión a finales de
messenal no voy a especular sobre lo que
hará Rusia o el presidente Putin el 24
pero lo más importante es que vemos cómo
están enviando tropas más armas más
capacidades para intentar presionar a
los ucranianos
para Putin capturar backmuth
representaría una victoria tras varios
meses de reveses y daría Rusia un nuevo
punto de apoyo en la región de donniesk
por su parte kiev dice que está frenando
los avances rusos pero la munición se
les está acabando está el temberg afirmó
que kiev está gastando munición más
rápido de lo que se puede producir y la
alianza está haciendo esfuerzos para
aumentar el suministro
Ucrania pide también aviones de combate
y misiles de largo alcance dos temas que
figuran en el orden del día de la
reunión de ministros de varios países de
la otan en Bruselas Este martes